i think i have a good balance of like
right and left brain
so i i
can be very creative and and have all of
those things but i also
understand like getting things done in a
certain amount of time and being
efficient and
uh
all the other elements that come with
directing that have are about you know
leading the the team as well
um being a leader on set
so i think
directing is very much like you've got
to have both sides uh not just being
creative and not just being
you know logistically figuring things
out it's like kind of having
both um
so i think i kind of have both of those
sides
do you ever lose your cool
um have you ever just been like shut the
[ __ ] up
yeah oh yeah really
but uh sometimes that to me it's not
even losing cool it's just like what's
necessary in the moment
right if if it's you know like things
are out of hand it's like sometimes you
have to
it's like real things back in and if
doing it like okay guys like okay guy
everybody like isn't working like you
then you gotta
do what works and is it do you find that
you have different
ways of directing to different actors
like oh brandon brandon could take
direction i'll give it to him this way
he could i could be hard on him and he
could just he can go with it this one i
need to coddle a little bit this one do
you find that oh for sure for sure um
it's kind of like two especially the
some some actors want to know why they
you know and they want that explanation
and they want to get into the
the the feelings and all the stuff
behind it and other actors are like
you know you should do it because
sometimes too it's like if you need
say you want the an actor to do the line
facing
turn like you want them to do the line
facing this way right because if they
turn over their shoulder like that you
have a whole nother setup you have to
turn around
and get that line and it's going to take
you know and you and if you don't have
that time
you need them to say it that way and so
it's some actors you're like hey we're
going to get out of here way faster if
if you play that line forward actors
that kind of know what they're doing
they'll say those things yeah i think a
lot of actors who've been in tv for a
long time uh it's
they
they can rationalize it and do it
themselves easily um other actors do not
want to hear about camera don't do not
it's insulting to be you know like hey
can you throw that line like for this
way for you know it's like
you you need to be like you know i
actually think you know they
you're so mad at them right now they
don't even want to look at them and so
you know it's like don't even like it's
you can't even they don't even deserve
your your eye contact you know whatever
it is it's
there was something i forgot like
oh maybe cindy lemay booker
but there was a direction about he
needed the actress to
uh fire a gun and she was doing it so
quick and it was like couldn't even see
it
but
you could tell that actor like hey
you're going so fast like we can't even
see you so just you know um be up there
slow it down and be up there longer
or you tell the actress like
you need to make sure you really get a
good aim because you can't just fire it
without taking aim so make sure you've
got you know you lock eyes before you
fire
and now
that actress instead of being like
boom it's you know she's coming up and
actually has something to do motivation
yeah which is such a gift because that
then you know and if you can communicate
something like that quickly i think
every actor would prefer that
than the
you know just being like camera need you
longer because then they have to come up
with their own justification but
it's it's sometimes hard to think of a
concise way to say things and so
a lot of times directors if you're like
oh you know because you don't want to
look at that person and you know and
it's too long um but if you can be
concise about everything i think
everyone would always prefer
an action to you know kind of do
do you really love it i could tell your
passion you just like when you're
talking about it when you're
it's it's just you could see it how much
of a passion you have for it i it's cool
i think i
needed the challenge too after being
playing this character for so long
um
sarah lance yeah sarah lance
lance sarah lance sarah lance and i i
needed uh
to be creatively
stimulated and challenged
and directing is
incredibly challenging over stimulation
it's i mean it's so much work
so much work
it really is and i think
i'm assuming it gets easier the better
you get because you just
you know you know yeah uh whereas right
now it's like
i really think
everything through
you